dr fauci spent the years leading up to
the coronavirus outbreak colluding with
chinese communists on gain of function
research to make naturally occurring
viruses more dangerous now
before you censor me there's been a lot
of censorship even even in yesterday's
show there was a little bit of
censorship from some big tech people
i just want you to know
i am not merely stating my own
hypothesis or opinion
actually i'm just quoting dr fauci who
made a freudian slip
and admitted to conspiring with the
commies
saw's
kovi one
clearly originated in china and we were
fortunate to escape
a major pandemic so we really had to
learn a lot more about the viruses that
were there about whether or not people
were getting infected with bad viruses
so in a very minor collaboration as part
of a subcontract of a grant we had a
collaboration with some chinese con
chinese uh scientist
and and what he conflated that is that
therefore we were involved in creating
the virus which is the most ridiculous
majestic leap i've ever heard of the
workers of the world must unite and
throw off our bonds of oppression and
seize the means of production because
we're all commun
i mean
scientists yeah that's the ticket
that is a freudian slip that is
when you say one thing but you mean your
mother and dr fatchi's slip is perfectly
natural
this is the point that we've been making
for years and that dr fauci has been
denying for years
in china
the scientists are communists
because the public health officials work
for
the communist party
public health public health is by
definition always
political incredibly it seems the only
difference between the chinese eggheads
and our own their public health
officials and ours is that the chinese
communists
are more honest about it i'm michael
knowles and this is the michael show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from
joe2648 who says if we can extend 15
days to slow the spread into two years
we surely can extend christmas for 12
days i totally agree with that it is
still christmas christmas is 12 days
long my friends it goes on until
epiphany on thursday so merry christmas
let's extend christmas
and let's shrink the time that we need
to
slow the spread all right let's this is
a wonderful christmas season it's time
to be nice and comfy and grateful and
cozy one great way to stay cozy would be
to get in your bowl and branch sheets no
one wants to cut corners on what's
important and few things matter more
than a good night's rest
bowl and branches signature sheets feel
so soft and light you will forget that
you are not actually sleeping on a cloud
no you're just sleeping on sheets they
just happen to be the best sheets in the
world i really love them
i've had the opportunity to sleep on
really fancy sheets when i go to fancy
hotels which has happened two or three
times in my life at least and it's
really great and you think why can't i
do this every single night well you can
with bowlin branch they're a bestseller
for a reason buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton in a classic sateen weave
for sheets that get softer and softer
over time not too hot not too cool i got
these as a wedding present for myself
i have given these to friends and family
they're just absolutely wonderful
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bowlingbranch.com get 15 off
your first set of sheets when you use
promo code michael mich ael at checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l and branch
dot-com promo code michael b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot-com promo code michael
this
is not the bombshell that dr fauci
would seem to be dropping here the fact
that in china the public health
officials are communists they are and
he's trying to then obscure that fact he
says no i'm just talking about the
scientists no but of course they are
they're
if you're working for the government if
you are for instance like dr fauci
taking a paycheck from the government
for decade upon decades throughout seven
presidential administrations if you're
the highest paid official in the federal
government you are
by definition a politician so when dr
fauci says i don't do politics i've
never had any political role i'm just a
scientist that's bogus it's it in the
very nature of the job that's not
possible
and so at least at least the chai comms
say what you will about the chai comms
but at least they're kind of honest
about it they say yes you you work for
us
you are answerable to us the premier the
dictator the chinese communist party
whereas here our public health officials
pretend that they're merely following
the science when of course they are
advancing a political agenda
speaking about differences between
totalitarian
countries and our wonderful democracy
where everything is free and open and
transparent
a sitting member of congress has just
been de-platformed kicked out of the
public square by a couple of
billionaire big tech oligarchs because
they don't like what she has to say
that would be marjorie taylor greene
marjory taylor green
first had her twitter account suspended
permanently
and then had her facebook account taken
away
for quote repeated violations of the
kovit 19 misinformation policy now if
spreading misinformation about kovite 19
is the sort of offense that gets you
kicked out of the public square then dr
fauci should be banished not just to a
far-flung island in the middle of the
pacific he should be banished to mars
he is the biggest super spreader of
misinformation about coronavirus that
there is but it's not just him it's cnn
and msnbc it's the director of the cdc
it's the head of the world health
organization it's joe biden it's all
these other people
who told us things about the virus and
the vaccines and the masks that they
themselves admitted later on were not
true and we went through all of those
yesterday and then apparently on a
couple of the big tech platforms uh we
we were censored which is very
unfortunate we'll get we'll get to more
on censorship in a little bit
but but if if there were an objective
standard
then
marjorie taylor green should not be the
one being kicked off it should be it
should jimmy fauci and don lemon and
kamala harris and and all the rest of
the liberal establishmentarians
now some conservatives are not defending
marjorie taylor green and this really
bothers me this really really bugs me
because what these conservatives are
doing is they're saying
that look marjorie taylor green she's
she's pretty kooky
she's pretty out there she's said things
on social media that i don't agree with
and that are really outlandish and about
space lasers and i can uh don't let me
in with her
no threats throw her over the side of
the boat and let's just come on i don't
want to be lumped in with her
let's grant all it let's say that she
said the craziest kookiest things in the
world on on social media
she is still much more trustworthy than
the people who run twitter and facebook
and on things that actually matter i'm
not talking about space lasers i'm
talking about how our political system
works on things that actually matter she
is infinitely more trustworthy than the
people who run twitter and facebook the
very people who are subverting our
self-government and who are
cutting off the people's dually elected
representatives from having speech which
is the way we govern ourselves in a
republic
okay don't
goodness gracious don't
go squishy here folks do not allow your
desire to seem above it all to seem very
erudite to seem like a conservative not
not one of those conservatives i'm a
really reasonable one i'm
do not let your desire
to be invited to fancy cocktail parties
and
not to be looked on as a kook at some
fancy institutions do not
uh
let that lead you to a place where
you're choosing the side of the oligarch
billionaire actual conspiracy theorists
to spread lies and conspiracy theories
about kovid specifically
to take their side over the side of
someone who is largely on your own side
in the republican party in the
conservative movement whose heart is
generally in the right place who's
generally fighting for the right sort of
things don't pick the side of the evil
rotten
terrible leftist revolutionary people
who want to silence you and destroy your
way of life don't pick their side
over margery green just because she said
some eccentric things before okay
this is a real choice
what kind what kind of
conservative do you want to be assuming
hurricanes i know that there are a
number of liberals and even leftists who
listen to the show and we we love you we
thank we appreciate you tuning in
hopefully we'll pull you over to our
side
but
if you're a conservative
what kind you want to be
do you want to be the kind who
boldly stands for what you stand for
or do you want to be the kind that sucks
up to the liberal establishment tries to
get an msnbc gig because then then
that's fine but then you got to follow
liz cheney then you got to follow adam
kinzinger
liz janey just came out
she always she hadn't been on tv in a
while she needed a little more attention
so liz cheney came out she said the gop
needs to choose
between
the constitution
and donald trump
i think that the
the american people again and
particularly the republican party you
know we as republicans have a choice to
make i am a conservative republican i
believe strongly in
the policies of low taxes and limited
government and a strong national defense
i think the country needs a strong
republican party going forward but our
party has to choose we can either be
loyal to donald trump or we can be loyal
to the constitution but we cannot be
both and uh right now there are far too
many republicans who are trying to
enable the former president embrace the
former president look the other way and
hope that the former president goes away
trying to obstruct the activities of
this committee but we won't be deterred
donald trump is going to have been dead
for 30 years and this frivolous woman is
still going to be talking about how
donald trump is the great he's going to
come back from the grave he's going to
dig himself up and he's going to storm
the capital and
he's a threat to the concert we need to
vote for joe biden
the man who's pushing uh
unconstitutional nationwide vaccine
mandates through osha we need to vote
for joe biden the man pushing abortion
on demand without apology slaughtering a
million babies a year we need to vote
for joe biden the man who's flagrantly
disrespecting our our national borders
and flooding the country with foreign
nationals we need to vote for joe biden
in order to stand with the constitution
not that mean old donald trump
who
what did he do what did he do that was
so bad what he sent some tweets and he
some people went to the capitol and he
told them to go home and huh what was
that
what is
saddest about liz cheney is not just the
inanity although the babble that she
regularly spouts is very inane
it's
how one note it is it's so monotone lady
get some new material goodness it's been
months of this come on get some
come go back to the drawing board give
me something give me some other reason
to tune in to msnbc or cnn
if you want to support america of course
you gotta you gotta vote for the right
people you gotta support the right
causes and you've got to support
american ranchers if you ask me that's
why i would recommend you check out good
ranchers i don't know about you but i
hate being lied to i don't and i really
hate when that happens with my food it
turns out that 85 of the grass-fed beef
in the united states
is not from the united states it's
imported from overseas
so why do they why will they say
product of usa as they often label this
beef when these these products are
minimally processed here don't buy cheap
imported beef that lacks true flavor go
to
goodranchers.comwles to cut through the
misinformation and get 100 american beef
delivered to your door today
good ranchers only sells beef that is
born
raised and harvested right here in the
good old u.s of a they're 100 american
in steakhouse quality all their steaks
are usda prime and choice graded means
that the steakhouse can come to you in a
good rancher's box of meat
rib eyes t-bones gourmet burgers the
burgers are amazing save 30 bucks today
with my code noel scanner wlas at
checkout that's 30 bucks off any box
biggest discount they've ever offered go
to goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles today to save big on your new
favorite steak they are the exclusive
meat company of the daily wire for good
reason they know great meat they have a
great cause supporting american farms
and feeding american families take your
grilling and steak nights to a whole new
level with good ranchers
goodranchers.com slash knowles save 30
bucks and make 2022 your most flavorful
year yet
speaking of tired material and stabbing
friends in the back
pat oswal
decided to spend his new year
and the following days
uh stabbing
his
friend of many decades dave chappelle
in the back
because dave chappelle did him a favor
and then pat oswalt got pushback from
the liberal mob
and so pat and oswald decided to try to
throw his friend his much more talented
and famous friend over the over the side
of the boat
this was what started it all off was one
instagram post from pat oswalt
this was uh new year's day i think or
i think it was new year's day it was
finished my set at mac hall
and got a text from dave chappelle come
over to the arena he's performing at
next door and do a guess out why not i
waved goodbye to this hell year with a
genius i started comedy with 34 years
ago he works in arena like he's talking
to one person and charming their skin
off anyway i ended the year with a real
friend and a deep laugh can't ask for
much more there's that picture of
dave chappelle and pat and oswald that's
really nice that's really nice you know
a nice grateful post from pat oswalt and
i and dave chappelle did his friend a
favor and that's a lovely way
to spend the new year
except here's the problem
dave chappelle
sort of kind of like once or twice
contradicted the leftist orthodoxy
and patton oswalt is a leftist coward
two issues here he's a leftist he does
push left-wing
ideas
and he's a coward before the mob and so
right away he publishes this essay
on instagram of him really thoughtfully
sitting at a pen and paper writing his
public apology to the mob
he says i saw a friend i hadn't seen in
a long time this new year's eve we've
known each other since we're teens he's
a fellow comedian the funniest i've ever
met i wanted to post a pic and an
instagram story about it so i did that
friend is dave chappelle 34 years we've
been friends he's refocused and refined
ideas a lot of us took as settled about
his race and history and life on planet
earth and spun them around with a fraser
punch line we've done bad and good gigs
open mics and tv tapings but we also 100
disagree
about transgender rights and
representation so there it is there it
is right he's he's justifying seeing a
friend of 34 years
he's saying
well if we'd only been friends for 10
years maybe i wouldn't have settled but
almost 34 years i had to i had to go
over
i don't even i don't even really like
the guy and he's like he's a good
comedian right he's funny and
ah but i had to and and but i'm sorry
but we disagree and he's a bigot and
he's a trans phobe and he's a bad person
and i'm a good person
we 100 disagree
about transgender rights and
representation i support trans people's
rights anyone's rights to live safely in
the world as their fullest selves for
all the things he's helped me evolve on
i'll always disagree with where he
stands now on transgender issues
but i also don't believe a seeker like
him has done evolving learning so it's
hey look my friend dave who i have to be
nice to because we've been friends for
34 years he's evil he's evil he's
totally evil i'm a good person but look
he's not
a hundred percent evil
he's still got a little glimmer of
potential goodness in him so i'm like
basically i'm just trying to help him be
a good person and you should really you
should be grateful to me
because i'm trying to help this evil man
reform
blah blah blah he goes on
he just goes on and babbles a little bit
more
this is really pathetic and
and and
mean and cruel and rude and all these
awful things to do to your and disloyal
and all
really a terrible way to treat your
friend it's also dishonest because
patent oswald has for a long time made
jokes about transvestitism and sexually
confused people for instance
you said this is for like families and
kids
because this sounds really grim and
creepy well you didn't let me finish
because we're also going to have men in
bright clothing and makeup up time out
do you mean like
like transvestites right
well technically yes but they're going
to keep going so that they're clowns you
realize a clown is just a transvestite
that doesn't stop
like if you like if you
if you saw a guy in lipstick and i
should be like timmy leave him alone
that's his own thing the guy's like oh
no hang on
like oh timmy get he's a wonderful clown
get over there
i didn't know you'd use a whole tube of
lipstick on one cheek please
entertain my child
run at him out of the darkness he'll
love it
so
the premise of the joke it's funny
enough joke premise of the joke is that
transgender people
are really just confused and the thing
that makes them transgender is that they
put on a lot of makeup so if they put on
a lot of makeup but stop at a certain
point then they're called transvestites
or transgender but if they keep going
the logical conclusion of that will be
that they're a clown furthermore the
other premise of this joke is that if
you see a transvestite it would be
natural to try to keep your kid away
from that transvestite because the
transvestite is obviously a little bit
confused
on some pretty important matters and so
you just say hey johnny don't maybe
don't go over there leave that person
alone don't talk to that person
right
but dave chappelle's a terrible person
because he said that men are not women
this is this is something
about these people
the
patton oswalts of the world the liz
cheney's of the world and the people who
take their side
that is
it's the insult to the injury the
disloyalty
would be bad enough the cowardice would
be bad enough the ignorance and naivete
that if you just grovel to the mob they
won't attack you anymore which just
never actually happens if you just
apologize for something that you haven't
done wrong then maybe the mob will will
move on but it's also the dishonesty
they don't believe this stuff
patton oswalt and dave chappelle i
seriously doubt disagree on the
transgender stuff what what pattern
oswald just said about transgenderism is
way more offensive than anything dave
chappelle has said
it's ju it's just the coward it's just
the going along to get along
it's
liz cheney
is not a republican i know that she's
got an r next to her name still sort of
i guess although her own state
republican party voted her out they said
you're no longer in the party get out
see a sayonara lady
and what does she say she says look i'm
a republican
i'm a i'm a lifelong conservative
republican i support okay what makes you
a conservative liz cheney
she lists it out
she says i support low taxes
limited government
and a strong national defense
those are euphemisms
certainly the latter two are euphemisms
for
letting
corporations generally speaking woke
corporations do whatever they want
on the one hit that's the low taxes and
the and the limited government the
deregulation
let woke
oligarchs do whatever they want and bomb
the middle east
so you know i'm a good i'm a
conservative republican i'm i am doing
what the liberal establishment wants
that's why i'm a conservative republican
that does not a conservative make
darling
on every
crucial issue
whenever it really counts whenever it's
difficult on a tough vote
liz cheney sides with the democrats
you saw this on the preposterous
impeachment of donald trump impeachments
of donald trump
you see this on the preposterous january
6th committee january 6th not only was
it not the worst insurrection
in american history not only has no one
involved been charged with insurrection
it wasn't even the worst insurrection
of of that year
the blm insurrection was way worse
attacked way more federal buildings
killed
infinitely more people because the the
capital riot didn't didn't end up
killing anyone it was just the cops who
killed one of the
capital demonstrators
way more arson vandalism theft robbery
but on those crucial votes
liz cheney sides with the dems
don't do that don't don't do this with
march retailer green don't you might
object to a lot of things the marriage
retailer green says i'm i'm sure you do
who but who's you on liz cheney's side
are you on patent oswald's side i don't
think so folks politics is about
alliances and and teams and i know we're
we're not supposed to acknowledge that
and we're all supposed to just pretend
that we're all atoms floating in the
ether but that's not how politics
actually works you do have to come
together usually with people you
disagree with on on some issues to
actually accomplish something
speaking of misinformation
rachel maddow
my doppelganger i try not to go after
her too much
you know i feel a certain kinship to her
might be an actual kinship i don't know
we've never taken a dna test rachel
maddow
has
spread
misinformation about
the coronavirus
it means that instead of the vaccine
being able excuse me it means for
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person to
person spreading and spreading sickening
some of them but not all of them and the
ones that it doesn't stick and don't
know they have it and then they give it
to even more people because they didn't
recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug-resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus
stops with every vaccinated person a
vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
it cannot use a vaccinated person as a
host to go get more people
that means
the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
if we just go fast enough to get the
whole population vaccinated
so what she said is not true and it's
now been contradicted by the public
health authorities this is a great
example because
ms maddow and i might bear some passing
similarities okay some passing
resemblance and yet she says false
things and doesn't get censored i say
true things that now even the public
health officials admit are true
and i do get censored why is that what's
going on here why
has that been the case for the whole of
the
lockdown and the pandemic and whatever
and why does that continue to be
the case we'll get to that
first though the daily wire has led the
charge to sue the biden administration
for the vaccine mandates now we're
taking it all the way up to the supreme
court
this friday the supreme court will
convene to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality of the
mandate
which means this week is going to be
huge in our fight against the mandate we
have over 1 million signatures on the do
not comply petition currently
it's vital that this number increases
before friday help us send our message
loud and clear head to dailywire.com do
not comply right now i think you know at
this point that the supreme court looks
at the polls they look at the news
headlines okay you've seen this in a lot
of court cases in recent years we're
counting on you to help us put a stop to
this federal overreach we'll be right
back with a lot more
so rachel maddow has gone on air and
said that the vaccines 100 percent
prevent people from contracting
the virus one and transmitting the virus
to 100 the virus just stops at that
person and that's why if enough people
get the vaccine the virus will just
completely stop now i know that
apparently
i can be censored and have been censored
on youtube for pointing out that this is
not true which is why i would recommend
you go to the audio podcast the apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
there
and you will get the un completely
uncensored you won't have to deal with
youtube or any of the other big tech
sensors there
but
you don't need to just take my word for
it
all of the major public health officials
have
directly contradicted what rachel maddow
said
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission you know we didn't have
vaccines that block transmission we got
vaccines that help you with your health
but they only slightly reduce the
transmissions we need a new
new way of doing the vaccine the level
of virus in the nasopharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected
is the same level
as the level of virus in the nasal
parents of an unvaccinated person
reports from our international
colleagues including israel
suggest increased risk of severe disease
amongst those vaccinated early
and if you look at israel
which has always been a month to a month
and a half
ahead of us they are seeing
a waning of immunity not only against
infection
but against hospitalizations
and to some extent death a booster might
actually be an essential part
of the primary regimen that people
should have
so there you have it rachel maddow says
one thing
the public health officials directly
contradict what she said in this case
only much later only long after the fact
but it does happen to be the case that
what the public health officials have
said in this specific case is true what
rachel maddow said was completely wrong
so my question the babylon bee asked
this question yesterday
why is she not being kicked off of
twitter for misinformation
she has spread much more misinformation
about kovid than marjorie taylor green
has why does marjorie taylor green get
kicked off of social media but rachel
maddow does not
why does this show
which has an extraordinarily good record
in terms of uh calling the shots on this
virus
why does this show
more i hate you know i hate to say i
told you so you know i hate to toot my
own horn
probably more accurate than
almost any other show
if not every single other show
on on the coronavirus from day one
how come we get censored but rachel mata
who's been dead wrong for most of it
she doesn't get censored because i have
actually the answer to that
it is not about what you say
it is about
who is saying it
it isn't it actually it is not now nor
has it ever been
about what is
said about the virus
it is about
who does the saying it
this is the issue i've run into
with some of the big tech platforms
when new information comes out about the
virus information that
some of us intuited early on but let's
say finally the cdc or the fda or who
admits it
i'm allowed to play a clip
of rochelle wallensky the cdc director
or dr fauci or any of them
saying something
if i then
repeat verbatim what they said i can
have my show taken down
because if what if what they said and i
said contradicts the rules against
misinformation
if i i can play the clip
of dr fatchi saying something i can then
say word for word what he said in the
doctor fought you voice by the way which
is fairly close to how he actually
sounds
but if i say it the show can be taken
down
because it's not about what is said it's
about who says it i talked to my friend
mike anton about this over christmas you
know we put some interviews out on the
channels over christmas one of which was
with my friend mike anton
he's at the claremont institute
he he wrote the famous flight 93 essay
in the 2016 election
and uh
we were talking about this strange
phenomenon
of
the
the legitimacy of of what you're allowed
to say differing based on who says it
and the example he brought up was the
great replacement theory
you might have heard about this this is
the the left has is fear-mongering now
and scaremongering about the great
replacement theory and they say you're
not allowed to talk about the great
replacement theory only white
supremacist racist nazi people talk
about the great replacement theory and
they accuse tucker of doing this and
a lot of conservative media
personalities and politicians
what is the great replacement theory the
great replacement theory is that
the left wants to change the
demographics of america to give them an
electoral advantage and they'll do this
through mass migration and and things
like that
here's a quote from anderson cooper
quote
the idea that you know whites will not
be the majority i mean that's it's an
exciting transformation of the country
it's an exciting evolution and you know
progress of our country in many
different ways
that's anderson cooper cnn
uh jorge ramos on univision says quote
there's nothing really they can do
against this incredible demographic
revolution he's talking about
conservatives saying that conservatives
rely on white people to win elections
and so there's nothing they can do this
is they're going to be replaced and then
they'll win
michelle goldberg writing in the new
york times
had a headline quote we can replace them
right that was the headline and so i i
was talking to
mr anton about this
and i said i don't
they're they're telling us that they
support this thing of the replacement
and sometimes in those exact words
and then
if we
say what they said then we're not
allowed to say that is that and he said
yes that's the
the defining feature here
they can say things
you can't say
those same things
and you can't even say
that they said those things
this is what we're seeing with
coronavirus how crazy is this what world
are we living in
dr fauci
can say something i'm not allowed to say
that same thing i'm not even allowed to
say that dr fauci said that thing
and it makes perfect sense because the
way that the left is looking at politics
is not as the right often looks at
politics which is about the free
marketplace of ideas and the way to
debate these things and and wright has
might and and the truth will win out in
the end and we just need to you know
have respect the views of of other
people and and the best ideas are going
to win out no that's not how they're
viewing it
they are viewing politics as
they support their friends and they hate
their enemies
that's it
and when their friends do something
they're going to support that
and when we their enemies
do even if we do if we say the same
thing or do the same thing they're going
to oppose that and and that's that
okay and those are two fundamentally
different ways
of looking at politics
but complaining about it isn't going to
do anything i'm never going to stop the
rain by complaining and neither are you
we i think we just probably need to
change our strategy a little bit and
recognize that the way our political
system actually works is different than
what many of us have been duped into
believing or duped ourselves into
believing
now speaking of replacing people
here's an essay from pink news
i'm sure that's your home page
i'm sure you all you chat you wake up in
the morning
dailywire.com pink news and okay here's
the
here's the headline
protesting trans athletes is not about
fairness or safety
it's about transphobia
so
i keep an open mind
read this article
and i think they actually make a really
good point
i think they make a really good point
the the right has
made a crusade about women's sports and
how unfair it is that
men are now competing in women's sports
and they're winning the women's sports
because men are physically stronger than
women
and what
pink news and the transgenderists and
the liberals are saying is you don't
really care about women's sports you
just oppose transgenderism and the thing
is they're right
they're right i don't care about women's
sports i care inasmuch as it is unjust
that the girls
have to compete again like go
race against people who are who are men
and therefore much faster than they are
or after especially oh my goodness in
some kind of combat sport or wrestling
or something could you even imagine
yeah i i don't like the injustice of
that but i don't
okay very few people watch the wnba
so i i just couldn't possibly care less
if some man
tries out for the wnba and wants to be
on one of the teams and i don't care i'm
not going to watch it anyway and no no
one really cares
you're right it's not
the issue of transgenderism is not
primarily about fairness or safety the
headlines right
it's about reality
okay it's
the real issue of transgenderism is not
that if we
make all the bathrooms unisex that
you know rape is going to scott there
will be an increase in rape but it's not
going to
skyrocket i don't think it's going to
become an epidemic it's it's the issue
of transgenderism is not that
you know women will now lose their
natural or human right to win soccer
games i mean yeah they won't win the
games anymore but it's not the biggest
issue in society the issue the issue is
that men aren't women and it's just the
issue is that transgenderism is
erroneous it's just it's false
and so we don't
support false things but the reason that
conservatives keep trying to frame this
as an issue of fairness or safety is
because a lot of conservatives i think
share the same
basic world view as the liberals do
namely it's it's a extremely skeptical
worldview that says we can never really
know anything about truth or goodness or
justice or beauty and you do you and
i'll do me and one man's terrorist is
another man's freedom fighter and it's
just extremely skeptical well we can't
impose our morality on others well we
need to teach students how to think not
what to think all those kind of
platitudes that are ultimately just
expressing a radical skepticism that we
can never really know anything at all
that the people who say that if we ban
drag queen story hour from the library
why
the libs might ban us from going to
church yeah that's a
as if you can't tell the difference
between a pervert working for a toddler
and going to church on sunday right but
that is the kind of radical skepticism
that some people on the right
share and an extreme
individualism
this radical idea of of
rights that this conception of rights
that's always expanding that we have the
right to do drugs we have the right to
dress up however we want we have the
right to redefine reality that
basically a lot of conservatives share
that i think with the libs
and so we'll say well it's you see the
the right of the man to dress up like a
woman is infringing now on the right of
the girl to win the soccer game and that
well i don't think that's going to be
really persuasive
i don't i think the only way that
conservatives are really going to push
back on the transgenderism issue is if
we grow a spine
while we're while we're talking about
manipulating our anatomies we should
grow a spine and we should
say things that are true and have the
confidence of our convictions which
conservatives used to have until recent
decades
and say no men
men simply aren't women
the the premise of transgenderism is
erroneous error has no rights there is
no right for a man to pretend to be a
woman
there is no way to neatly parse out
private life from public life so that
you say that the man has the right to
pretend to be a woman in his home but
not in public that's never going to work
that has never worked in any society
we're not just atoms floating in the
ether but we do live together in a in a
society and so the way that we view
ourselves and our relationship to our
bodies and the relationship to society
in our homes is going to affect the way
that we do that in public too and sorry
buster if you're confused and you think
that you're a woman
you should get help for that we should
you know try to give you the resources
to work through these difficulties that
you've got but we're not going to
indulge that delusion because it's not
because of safety or even fairness
because it's wrong and we know it's
wrong and we know that some things are
right and some things are wrong and
that's that
do do conservatives
have the husba
to say that if we do
then i think
there's a chance
then i think
we we could win on this issue then i
think we could reclaim some of our
culture
if we don't if we're going to keep just
making these disingenuous arguments
about how much we care about women's
soccer when we don't really uh then i
don't think we're gonna persuade anybody
this is this is what the school fight is
all about there was a video just went
viral on tick tock of a preschool
preschool teacher talking about how she
is indoctrinating her kids in
transgender ideology
says to the parents who refuse to
educate their kids on queerness i'm an
openly non-binary trans preschool
teacher
i talk to my students about pronouns
transness gender expression and
sexuality
[Music]
right you you parents think you're going
to keep this away from your kids well no
because i'm going to teach them about it
now i i give the
woman or man or non-binary or i don't
know i'm not going to venture a guess
here
i give this individual
some credit at least for
the courage of his or her convictions
a lot of conservatives won't
won't say what they need to say which is
we need to ban these ideas from the
classroom right that's what the parents
in loudoun county and elsewhere are
saying they're saying we don't want you
can't shouldn't teach our kids a bunch
of false nonsense about their sex or
their race or whatever
and a lot of the conservative elites
will say well no we don't we don't
support banning any ideas from the
classroom why not if you don't support
banning ideas from the classroom then
how do you stop that how do you stop
this lunatic pervert individual from
indoctrinating your three-year-old into
believing that little johnny is little
jane how do you do it
if you're not willing to stand by the
courage of your convictions how do you
stop it
speaking of
tick-tock lunatics there's another
i i go through these tick-tock videos
not only because they're amusing
they are amusing often but because
they're extremely educational and
extremely insightful like this
guy who is dressed up like a woman
who says you might oppose
transgenderism
but you will respect transgenderism
let me tell you something about lgbtq
right it's about
trends right
this is only going in one direction
you will respect us
you can be upset
you can be angry you can think it's
unfair you can feel like we're stealing
something from you
but it's still only going in one
direction
you will
respect us
he's right
he's right you will you will respect
transgenderism
you will because if you don't
you'll be punished
so you and you might not believe it in
your heart of hearts and you might still
think it's crazy but you will show
public respect for it because the boot
of the establishment will come down on
your neck if you don't
he's absolutely right
the the lie the delusion was
that these radical ideologies merely
seek
acceptance
just be tolerant
just be inclusive just be accepting
no it was never about that
they seek
affirmation
they demand affirmation they have to
why because we live in a society because
we're not just atoms floating in the
ether and so
you cannot have a society
in which the country is split
radically split on the question of what
is human nature
we have to agree on some things if we're
going to have a society and at the very
least you need to agree on what a human
being is
and if half the country
i don't think it's quite this much but
let's let's say it's the left believes
one thing the right believes the other
half the country believes that
human
nature has nothing to do with your body
and the other half believes that it does
and you know one half believes that men
can become women and do and the other
half believes that they can't you're not
going to be able to function you're not
going to be able to speak to one another
you're not going to know what pronouns
to use we currently don't know what
pronouns to use and so you're going to
have to resolve that question
at the public level
so what's it going to be
and what the liberals will tell you is
look you might have your personal
reservations about transgenderism but we
all need to agree on accepting it at the
political level
you might have your personal
reservations about abortion but we all
need to agree that we should kill 60
million babies since roe versus wade
and it's just a it's just a trick
it's just a little political slate of
hand that has given them the entire
culture
the live and let live language of the
left
was never real
it was never serious it was always an
instrument toward achieving their ends
academic freedom the free marketplace of
ideas live and let live it was always a
lie
okay and now the right is befuddled and
they'll say what happened to the
tolerance so much for the tolerant left
what happened to live and let live what
happened to they never meant it that's
what happened it was always a lie to
trick you into giving up your culture
and your standards
and now they've got the upper hand and
they are doing what they naturally would
do which is enforce their own standards
like all societies
so what's what's the alternative
the new york times tells us what the
alternative is
the new york times new york times it's
just like these wackos on tick tock
sometimes the new york times will
unwittingly give you the right answer to
political problems
guest essay
headline is what happened to poland
warsaw
not long ago poland was seen as the most
successful example of democratic
transformation in central and eastern
europe a leader in european integration
it was enjoying as the long-time
european commissioner gunter verhugen
wrote a new golden age today the country
is again ahead of others only this time
it's in the vanguard of european
disintegration and democratic
dismantling
poland possesses a traumatic nervous
sense of itself the current government
has tried to channel that anxiety
invading against migrants brussels and
liberals to create a fortress mentality
despite occasional setbacks such as the
president's decision to veto a
controversial media bill
it has succeeded
so what are they actually they're saying
that
poland was really democratic
when it was doing exactly what the
people in brussels the leaders of the
european union the people who were not
accountable to the citizens of poland
wanted them to do
so when
poland was suppressing the will of its
own people and just going along with
what a distant tyrant told them to do
that was democratic but now that poland
is doing what its own people want them
to do and doing what its own people
elected them to do now it's
anti-democratic do you see the problem
there
do you see
as i have said for quite a while i
actually wrote a book on this topic
called speechless controlling words
controlling minds the left has just
redefined democracy to mean not
democracy
they've completely switched the meaning
of democracy
how does this make any sense how do they
get away with it adrian vermeuel the
harvard law professor
one of the greatest twitter accounts has
a great sub stack also with some other
good good thinkers called the post order
adrian vermeel points out that
if you just switch out the words
democracy and liberalism things start to
make sense
what the left considers democracy
is
not when you follow the will of the
people but when you just go along with
some elite liberal idea this is why when
the people elect donald trump that's a
threat to democracy and it's why when
the people's will is thwarted that is a
vindication of democracy if it goes in
the left-wing
direction
so what are we gonna have which way are
we gonna what poland has done is become
much more conservative and said no to
the distant liberal elites in brussels
and has said yes to its own culture and
its own history and its own religion
it's become significantly more christian
don't forget poland played a big role in
the fall of the soviet empire
poland when the polls came out when
saint john paul ii walked up and they
chanted we want god we want god
they which way are we going to go are we
going to go in the direction of elite
liberal rule
or are we going to channel the
legitimate frustrations of the people
who no longer have confidence in their
own ruling class which seems
increasingly to despise them and
consider them deplorable and
irredeemable which side are we going to
take liz cheney's right that we need to
make a choice she's wrong about what
that choice is and she's on the wrong
side of it but we will need to make that
choice i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show democrats
obsessed over january 6 in order to
promote changing all the election rules
plus patton oswalt throws dave chappelle
under the bus that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen